Hello, this is Jin from Next Level
Commander and today we have the second
commander deck from Final Fantasy. It is
Counter Blitz, also collector's edition.
And once again, as usual, we are going
to open the deck, show the beautiful
cards, and also try to upgrade it, look
at some cuts, look at some replacements,
and upgrade this to a racket three if
possible. All right, let's take a look.
Okay, here is the rack. Uh the deck box
and
should be the same. We got the deck
here. Oops. Got the deck here
and
ah the pack and everything else. We'll
go to the side. Yeah, we'll first get
into the deck.
Let's see. So, we've got uh Titus, the
commander, and this commander is one
that works with counters. At the
beginning of combat on your turn, you
may move a counter from target creature
you control onto a target, a second
target creature you control. Uh,
whenever one or more creatures you
control with counter something, deal
combat damage to a player, you may draw
a card and proliferate. do this only
once each turn. Sure, it's once each
turn, but it's still pretty powerful,
right? Because you can Yeah, each turn
you can play for it once and draw a
card. And for three mana, this is quite
aggressive. It's nice to move around
plus one plus encounters, but when you
get into the sagas is when it gets
really spicy. So, Titus, we'll leave him
here. Next up, Yuna. Wow, nice.
I mean, I never played this game, Final
Fantasy 10, but these characters, it's
impossible to not know them. Okay, grand
summon. Add one mana of any color. When
you next cast a creature spell this
turn, that creature enters with two
additional counters on it. Plus one
counters on it. That's really good.
Whenever another permanent you control
is put into the graveyard if it had one
or more counters on it, you may put that
number of plus one plus one counters on
target creature,
you know. So it turns all your per so
all your counters stay basically even if
it's a saga. For example, the saga
creature dies at the end of the
chapters. You can convert those saga
counters into plus one counters and put
them onto a creature. So these two
commanders, they synergize really well
with each other. Yeah. Well, I mean,
this is our commander, but yeah, this
other legend.
So, this is a plus one counter deck, and
I think it's really wide open. You can
play plus one counters, you can play
saga, uh, lower lore counters, you can
do shield counters, all kinds of
counters. So, let's see what counters
this guy's about. Oron venerated
guardian vigilance. Whenever Oruron
attacks, put a plus one counter on it.
If you when you do, exile target
creature defending player controls with
power less than Oruron's power until
Oruron leaves the battlefield.
H. So, every combat you can exile
something. It's not overly powerful.
Yeah, it's a bit slow, but still we're
doing the counter synergy. And if we can
move some counters onto Oron, he can
exile some pretty large large defenders,
large creatures. So that seems decent
up here.
Next up, Chocobo Knights. Whenever you
attack creatures you control with
counters of them, gain double strike.
Holy, that is aggressive because all of
our creatures will have counters and
saga creatures are just naturally
countered. So super powerful.
Gata and Luzu
flash. When Gata and Luzu enters, choose
target creature you control. If damage
will be dealt to that creature this
turn, prevent that damage and put that
many plus one counters on it. H.
It's a cool trick, but I'm not sure this
is impactful. like you don't even kill
the uh it's I mean if you were going to
trade with the opposing creature sure
you can kill them now but otherwise you
chomp block and your creature gets big
but you're not even killing the blocked
creature.
So three mana flash uh technically you
can get a lot of counters but probably
not.
So again, this is a cool card, but I
don't think it's impactful enough. So I
will put it in the maybe pile because
I'm I'm imagining this deck I'm
expecting it to have lots of really
really good synergy. So this relatively
speaking is a bit weaker.
Okay, Lord Jasco Guad
flying at the beginning of each end step
you put a if you put a counter on a
creature this turn, investigate.
Uh, similar to the last card, it's a
cool effect, but
can we put counters on other people's
turn? I think that's what we're asking
here because if we just investigate
investigate once a turn, that's not a
strong ability, right? We are paying two
a turn to draw a card in I think green
white has better. I mean, we are in
blue, so blue, green, white, then we
have better draw effects than this. So,
yeah, we'll see if we have ways to place
counters onto opponent stuff. If not,
then this doesn't quite make it. So
maybe pile
protection magic. Put a shield counter
on each of up to three target creatures.
Yeah, this is pretty sweet because you
can shield three creatures and then
proliferate them and then move them
around. It's slow, but it can slowly
protect your board. And it's also just a
decent trick against board wives,
removals, anything like that. So solid
card. Summon summon Exion. Exile target
creature and opponent controls until the
this saga leaves the battlefield. So
it's a saga three three mana three three
and after you do this you can put post
one counters on each of up to two target
creatures you control and gain two life.
It's got first strike. It's not super
powerful but being able to
choose which ability to reuse with our
commander here. Yeah, we can just keep
triggering the first ability or we can
keep ex on the board just keep getting
the counters. I think it's a fairly
fairly reasonable cost for this effect.
And this deck with the cards we've seen
is looking a little bit aggressive. I
mean, even this guy, Lord Jasco, even
though he's not super impactful, it's a
two mana, two-1 flying. That's that's
solid, right? So, we'll see if this deck
is kind of aggressive uh on the beta,
but for now, yeah, I think someone is a
solid card to have.
Summon Yo Jimbo. Exile target artifact
enchantment or tapped creature. Yeah,
I'm already on board with this. This is
some sweet removal that has great
synergy with our commander. But after
this, we have until your next turn
creatures can't attack you unless their
controller pays two for each of those
creatures.
Seems solid propaganda. And again,
what's nice about about these abilities
is we have to remember we can just keep
using them with uh Titus and Titus can
just keep moving the lore counters onto
say another creature that doesn't care
about lore counters. Yeah. So, next up,
create X treasure tokens where X's
number of opponents who control a
creature of power four or greater. Yeah.
So, this is kind of situational, but I
mean, we got a five five vigilance for
four. This is a solid card that we can
keep around if we want to.
Okay, next up,
summoner sending.
At the beginning of your end step, you
may exile target creature card from a
graveyard if you do create a one- one
white spirit creature token with flying
and put a plus one counter on it. If the
exile card's mana value is four or
greater,
I don't think this is again impactful
enough. So every turn, okay, every turn
you can exile, you can graveyard hate
something and you might get a Oh, you
Well, if you exile a creature, you get a
spirit. So if you draw this early, it's
you might not have targets. If you draw
this late, it's too slow to do to be
impactful in the mid game or late game.
So I would say this is not really worth
it, even though the art is sick. Yeah,
I'll put this in the maybe pile for now
just because if you think about it,
early game, late game, this is not doing
too much either way. Next up, Blissball
Stadium. When this artifact enters,
support X. That's putting a counter on
each of up to X target creatures. Goal
for goal. Three mana tap until the end
of turn. Target creature gains whenever
this creature deals combat damage to a
player. Draw a card for each kind of
counter on it and it can't be blocked.
Okay, so it gives evasion to one
creature
and
like chances are our cre we would have a
creature with at least two kinds of
counters on it. So give it unblockable
draw two seems decent and the support X
is synergistic with our deck. I I'm not
sure. Again, this might also be a lower
impact card, but it seems like the
combination of abilities makes it kind
of worth it. Yeah, so I will keep it in
for now. Next up, Lulu Stern Guardian.
Uh, whenever an opponent attacks you,
choose target creature attacking you.
Put a stun counter on that creature. Oh,
there's a counter on our opponent. Yeah,
if we see more of these, we uh this
other guy here, Lord, Jascal might might
make it back in.
But yeah, we get stun counters onto
opponent's creatures. And remember, our
commander can proliferate those stun
counters. So, we can actually keep them
tapped basically forever, right? So,
that's decent. And also, she's got
proliferate herself.
Yeah, I think this is solid value and
just that four mana perfrate can do a
lot of work especially with sagas.
Oka traveling merchant two mana one two
remove straight up tap remove a counter
from a null and prominent you control
draw a card.
Um, this on its own is not really good,
but considering we have a lot of saga
creatures, this serves as another kind
of another ver another alternative or a
backup for Titus, our commander. Yeah.
So, considering that synergy, I think
Oka is good enough. Now, if it turns out
we only have like two or three saga
creatures, we're going to cut this. But,
I don't think so. It seems like we'll
have a lot more. That seems to be a
theme in the deck. So, we'll see about
that. Most likely, most likely she's
good enough. Riku, resourceful guardian.
Whenever you put one or more counters on
a creature until the end of turn, that
creature can't be blocked. Now, steel,
move a counter from target creature and
opponent controls onto target creature,
you control. H,
this also feels low impact, but giving
whenever one or more counters on a
creature.
So I guess in theory we can we can
proliferate. We can for example if you
put a counter on every creature we can
alpha strike but the problem is the
proliferate here is after we deal damage
right. Yeah it's after we do damage. So
doesn't work too well and the move
counter thing is like how do you know
your opponents are going to have
counters? I mean sagas will be popular
but we can't know for sure that we will
have targets for this and I don't see so
far I don't see a lot of mass counter
placement. So, this card I will say
maybe. I'll put it in the maybe pile.
Yeah, just because it feels lower impact
and also because the counters is so
common in Magic. Almost every set, every
other set has counter manipulation. So,
there will be tons of excellent cards to
to put into this deck that are much
higher impact. So, we are fairly strict
actually.
Summon Velfora
55 flying sonic wings. Each opponent
chooses a creature with the greatest
mana value among creatures they control.
Return those creatures to their owner's
hands.
Well, that's super strong. We can just
do this every turn with our commander.
Yeah. And it doesn't even matter what
the the other ability isn't too strong.
Seems like tap up to a creature and put
a stun counter on it. It's decent. But
this ability uh this first ability first
chapter is why we're here. And yeah,
this alone justifies the inclusion. I
think
Master Seymour
at the beginning of combat on your turn
put a number of plus one counters equal
to Master Seymour's power on another
target creature and then monstrosity X
where X is the number of creatures
number of counters among creatures you
control. Yeah, perfect synergy because
we can pump Master Seymour and then
Master Seymour will pump our other
creatures more and now we got this
escalating effect and eventually pretty
quickly our board will be massive. Yeah,
I imagine this deck is probably pretty
strong out of the box compared to the
other three, but we'll have to see when
we play when we play it. Sphere Grid.
Whenever a creature you control deals
combat damage to a player, it gets a
counter. And creatures you control with
plus one counters on them have reach and
trample. I was just about to say because
decks that go tall often times end up in
board stalls because we don't have
evasion. And this card gives us evasion
and also enables our counters. So, seems
solid for two mana.
Summon Magga Sisters.
Oh, another choose one at random. Is
that a cycle? Choose one at random.
Combine powers. Put three plus one
counters on target creature. Solid. Put
a shield counter target creature. You
gain life. You gain three life. Solid.
And then you can fight something. It's a
five mana, five, five haste. Yeah, this
tech is looking quite aggressive
honestly with the beatdowns. And because
this is choose one at random, we can't
really, you know, manipulate it too well
with our commander. We can keep it
alive. We can keep Magnusers Mega
Sisters alive, but we we don't really
get to know which ability it is. But all
three abilities are solid, I'd say. So,
worth worth playing. Truml Seymour's
Butler.
Each other non-token you control enters
with an additional plus one counter.
Seems good. And one tap proliferate X
times where X is the number of non-token
creatures you control that entered this
turn.
Uh,
so this will probably happen maybe once
a turn. I don't I don't think it will
happen twice a turn regularly,
but just having the creatures enter with
counters, I think, is solid. Yeah. And
being able to proliferate is and I like
the the potential upside because once in
a while you'll be able to proliferate
once, twice, and alpha strike someone.
It's slow. It's slow, but we'll keep him
for now. Next up, Ununas Decision.
Sacrifice a creature. If you do draw a
card, then you may put a creature cart.
Uh, I remember this card. I've opened it
in a pack, but this card I don't think
is great. Sure, you can return two
permanence.
It's decent late game, but not the best
re uh recursion spell, but also this
first ability is not great because we
don't we're not really cheating in
massive creatures, right? This deck is
kind of on curve, right? sacrificing a
creature just to put another farmer at
hand. I mean, contra compare this to
what's it called? Nature's Will is I
don't think it's even close.
So, yeah, I will put this in the maybe
pile.
Ununas Whistle.
H three mana. Reveal cards from the top
of your library until you reveal a
creature card. Put that card into your
hand and the rest on the bottom of
library. When you reveal a creature this
way, put X plus one plus one count
encounters on target creature you
control where X is the mana value. Holy,
this does have potential. I mean, it's
not amazing in this deck. Like, I can
imagine this being ridiculous in some
Voltron decks with larger creatures, but
it's still decent just because you get
to keep that creature and you get to
pump something at instant speed. So,
overall for three mana, I think it's
solid value. Pretty much cantrips. Yeah,
sure. Kimari, Valiant Guardian.
Uh, this
gets a counter and then you can tap
something and this becomes copy of that
opponent's creature or that creature
that opponent controls except it keeps
his name. So, I think they just put the
person on counter ability on it just to
force it into this deck. There's no not
really any synergy with anything.
Yeah, it's just it just gets a counter.
That's it. I mean, if your opponent has
cool creatures that use counters, sure,
you can use that. But right now, I don't
think this is a great fit in this deck.
So, maybe pile or maybe pile is
currently one, two, three, four, five,
six cards. Not bad. Yeah, this deck so
far has been more a bit more synergistic
than the previous one. The revival
trance, the Mardu deck. Yes.
Okay. Shelinda, Yavon, Acolyte,
Lifelink. Whenever another creature you
control enters, put a plus one counter
on that creature, if his power is less
than Shelinda's power. Otherwise, put a
plus one counter on Shelinda. So,
basically, whenever a creature enters,
you can put a counter on something,
either her or that creature. Two minutes
to two lifelink.
I don't think this is impactful enough.
Uh, I don't know. I I feel like again
because of how many amazing cards there
are for this strategy, I think she's a
bit slow.
But again, so far it seems like our deck
is actually fairly aggressive. And
having this early is decent.
But I I can I can still think of better
cards though. So for now, maybe maybe
pile sin unending cataclysm. Flying
trample 55. As sin enters, remove all
counters from any number of artifacts,
creatures, and enchantments. Sin enters
with X plus one counters on it where X
is twice the number of counters removed
this way. This is what I mean by
impactful. I mean it's seven mana but
most of your commander game will be
spent in mid late game and something
like this will yeah it will come down
and do a lot of work. When sin dies put
his counters on target creature control
then shuffle this card into his owner's
library.
Yeah. So when it enters you can steal
your opponent's plus one counters their
sagas. You can take their saga counters
and sin will be massive
and sagas will be popular. Sagas will
probably be everywhere I think now,
especially after Final Fantasy. So, this
is decent. It's not amazing, but I like
this. It's a cool card as a, you know,
we so far we haven't been been seeing a
lot of cards with high mana cost, and
having a nice top end like this is cool.
Yeah. So, we'll keep it for now. Waka,
Devoted Guardian, four mana, reach
trample. Whenever Waka deals combat
damage to a player, destroy up to one
target artifact that player controls and
put a plus one plus one counter on Waka.
And also at the beginning of your end
step, if a counter was put on Waka this
turn, put a plus one counter on each
other creature you control. Yeah, this
is what I call mid to high impact
reach trample. Yeah, it see. It's really
really powerful. It kills something.
It's like a trigon predator. It destroys
a artifact or enchantment and then it
gets a counter and then it puts a
counter on everything. Yeah, it does all
the all the things we want in this deck.
Collective effort. Sorcery.
Destroy target creature with power. Oh,
this is a reprint. Yeah, we are in
reprint territory now. But sorcery,
destroy target creature with power four
or greater. Destroy target enchantment.
Put a plus one count on each creature
target player controls. And you can
escalate to
uh you can escalate to pick more modes.
one, two, or up to three modes. But none
of the modes are it's like a removal.
Yeah, it's like a removal, but it's not
a great removal. Any sorcery removal
needs to be excellent. Like needs to be
boardwide tier to be to be good in EDH.
And also put a plus one counter on each
creature we control. It's just I don't
think it does enough. So I'd rather just
replace this with a premium removal or
even a boardw.
So uh maybe pile damning verdict.
Destroy all creatures with no counters
on them. Yeah, once again, you compare
this to collective effort. You can see
the difference. This is like a blowout.
Farewell. Not much to say. Sometimes you
just got a farewell.
Luminous brood moth. Well, that's a cool
inclusion cuz then your board becomes
board wipe proof except for farewell,
but normal board wipes. And you can then
move the flying counters onto other
creatures to reuse it again to reuse the
undying ability again. Yeah, we are not
a graveyard deck. We're not a sacrifice
deck, but just creatures dying
naturally, I think. And there's some
room for for manipulation for uh Yeah,
so seems good. Promise of loyalty. Each
player puts a vow counter on a creature
they control and sacrifices the rest.
Each of those creatures can't attack you
or a plan walker you control for as long
as it has a vow counter on it. This
doesn't have much synergy with our deck,
but it's a really good board wipe. A
solid board wipe. Yeah, I can't imagine
what you're going to move foul counters
onto things. You're going to proliferate
those val counters. There's not much we
can do there. But again, this is a
really good board wipe, so we keep it.
Resourceful defense. Whenever a
permanent control leaves the
battlefield, if it had counters on it,
put those counters on target permanent
control. You can move counters from a
permanent to another permanent.
This is excellent in a planaineswalker
deck, but in a creature deck, it's it's
decent.
Yeah, you can do some tricks like with
counter doubling effects, which we might
have later on.
Yeah, I think we'll keep it in for now
because it seems seems like there's a
lot of room for for play. We haven't
seen too much synergy with this yet, but
yeah, it seems like this is the kind of
card that uh Johnny would like. Yeah.
Scholar of New Horizons.
This creature enters with a plus one
counter and you can remove a counter
from a permanent you control. Search my
library for a plank and reveal it and I
can put it into play tapped if an
opponent controls more lands than me.
Yeah, this is the kind of early game we
want. Yeah, because we can play catchup
if our opponent is ahead in lands.
Doesn't seem like we have a lot of ramp
in here. If we do, this might be awkward
because we also have green. But if we
don't, then this is a solid inclusion.
Sunscorch Regent.
Yeah, this is this card doesn't have
much synergy with our deck, but it's
just one of the most powerful powerful
fatties in the format, I feel. Because
it's easily a, you know, 10 10 15 and
the life gang is also relevant.
Yeah. So again, I I don't see much
synergy, but it's just a massive massive
flying threat with counters.
The kind of card we need together
forever. If I cut this card, I might get
reported by thousands of people. Just
kidding. Nobody watches my videos. But
yes, when this enchantment enters
support two, uh, choose target creature
with a counter on it. When this
creature, when that creature dies,
return that card to his owner's hand.
Yeah, we're not cutting this card. This
card is great.
Basically, you can have one mana to just
return everything that dies.
One mana per creature. Yeah, it's an
excellent card. This is the kind of
payoff for counter counter decks we
need. Next up, Casm Skullker. Whenever
you draw a card, local one counter on
it. And when this creature dies, create
X11 blue squid creature tokens with
Island Walk where X is the number of
plus one counters on it.
Seems good. Yeah, we're we're lacking a
bit in the synergy department.
I guess fine to proliferate this to make
it bigger, but making the tokens
is decent. And also, we're not really a
sacrifice deck, so we don't really get a
control when this dies, but I guess it's
kind of like board wipe prevention. They
wipe. We we're left with a board of, you
know, 81 ones. It seems okay.
Inexorable Tide. Whenever you cast a
spell, proliferate.
Yeah, this seems good in this deck. It's
not at at its best because in this deck
we're casting maybe two spells a turn,
but even then it's a powerful effect.
So, we'll keep it in. Pull from
tomorrow. Just a solid draw spell. Now,
I'm surprised they put this in, but it's
definitely needed.
Draw X cards and discard a card. Again,
this deck is not making a lot of mana,
it seems like, but even then in the mid
game, doing this for four to five is
already really, really powerful. bane of
progress. When it enters, destroy all
artifacts enchants. Put a plus one
counter on this for each permanent
destroy this way.
Yeah, this is a solid removal. And so
far, we're seeing a lot of creatures
with a lot of counters on them, but our
commander isn't really a great payoff
for that because commander, the
commander removes one counter. It just
moves a counter from a creature to
another creature. Not really benefiting
from creatures that are massive with
large counters, large number of
counters. So, we'll see if we have some
payoff later on.
Next up, fight rigging. Hide away five.
At the beginning of combat on your turn,
put a plus 100 on target creature. Then,
if it has power seven or greater, you
can play the exile card without paying
his mana cost. Yeah. So, this can
trigger immediately with some of our
larger creatures. See, this is kind of a
decent payoff. Yeah, I like it. I like
it. It's going to trigger. So,
basically, it's three mana to cast a
spell from the top five for free. Seems
good. Forgotten Ancient, the classic
staple encounter decks. Not much to say.
You can redistribute counters onto
anything you want. You know, move 12 of
them onto our commander and we can alo
strike someone. Seems good. Next up,
Generous Patron. If you watched any of
my other videos, this is one of my
favorite cards just because it's a green
three mana ETB draw two because you're
not supporting onto your creatures
unless you have some sweet synergy
setup. You just put them onto your
opponent's creature uh opponent's
creatures. Yeah, and you can draw two
cards. And also with the, you know, the
stun counters and stuff, you'll be
drawing more cards. So, this seems good.
And also, does it work with our Titus?
We can Titus can move. No, it has to
move to creatures arc we control. But we
can use Titus proliferate. Like, if we
proliferate our opponent's counters, you
know, something like Saga, their lure
counters or their Pokemon counters, we
we can draw cards. So, this card is
excellent. Next up, Gyra Sage.
Uh, it's got evolve, so it gets bigger
and then it adds mana for each plus one
counter on it. Perfect. Just the card we
need. Harden skills whenever. Yeah, it
adds one more counter whenever whenever
we place a counter. Seems good.
Incubation Druid. I think it's similar
to Gyrus Sage. If it's got a counter, it
can add three mana. Solid. Path of
discovery. Whenever a creature you
control enters, it explores.
Honestly, this seems good in this deck,
but I don't like it just because
again, we're not having that many
creatures enter. We're not a token deck.
So, say again, we have two creatures
enter, what we're going to do, we are
going to draw it if it's a land and then
place a counter onto the second
creature. And that's just not very
impactful for a four mana enchantment.
Like, if it's a four mana 55 creature, I
would consider it. But this is much
better in a token deck where you can go
wide rather than a counter stack. So,
we'll put this in the maybe pile.
Rampant Rejuvenator. This creature
enters with two plus one counters on it.
When it dies, search your library for X
basic land cards.
Seems good. Again, we don't have we have
no control over our creatures dying. But
if it just dies naturally, is is a lot
of value. We'll be piling counters onto
this with our commander with other
effects. So, I think this again, you're
playing counter stack. You want to play
the ones that are synergistic, right?
You don't want to play the generic ram
spells and this is one of those counter
payoff cards.
Tireless Tracker whenever land interest
enters investigate and this is a really
powerful card and it kind of has
counters but there's no synergy with our
deck, right? What do we do with
investigate? I guess we crack them to
draw cards. But we're in blue. We have
better ways to draw cards. Yeah, this is
I I imagine they put this in as a draw
spell that has kind of counter synergy,
but the synergy is so weak and I think
there are better options. It's a sweet
card. I love this card, but not for this
deck. So maybe altered eagle just enters
as a copy of a creature with X plus one
counters on it. Can potentially be
really good if it's a creature that
cares about counters. For example, this
one. For example, if you clone rampant
rejuvenator, right, you can easily get
four or six counters onto it and when it
dies, you'll ramp six lands.
So there is some synergy here. Endless
detour. The owner of target spell. Non
land permanent or cart in a graveyard.
Shuffles it. Wait, puts it on the top or
bottom. Their choice though. So, it's
kind of a counter spell, kind of a
removal. Yeah, I think it's decent. I
think it's decent because it's versatile
enough that even though it's not a hard
counter, it's I think it's decent in
this deck.
Fathom Mage. Another staple in plus one
counter decks. Not much to say. This is
when you get this onto the board, you
will get so much value. Just protect her
at all costs. Yeah, she will she will
repay you. Walking ballista.
Four mana to put a counter onto it and
remove a counter to deal one damage.
seems kind of slow, but often times,
like on paper, this card is slow and
doesn't do much, but often times it's
surprisingly impactful, especially when
you have the plus one counter kind of
manipulation.
Um, I I was told that there's a combo in
this deck with with this card with
locking ballista, but I'm not sure. I'll
take a look to see, but on its own, I
think it's a fine card. Yeah, we'll have
to play with it to see, but yeah, I
think it's worth a try. Now, are we on
to lands yet? We are not. They they like
to pile the lands with non lens for some
reason. We're going to skip to the non
lens first. Yeah. Follow me once.
Um, here you go. Okay. Destroy evil. Two
mana. Choose one. Destroy creature with
toughness four or greater or destroy
target enchantment.
It's okay. It's passable, but there are
way better removals in in our colors.
So, I don't want to keep a card like
this in here. It just feels very
suboptimal.
Grateful apparition. Whenever this
creature deals combat damage to a player
playing smaller, proliferate.
Two amount of flying is proliferating
once a turn worth
I don't uh I don't know. I'm not sure
this is impactful enough because once
again, we are not going wide. we'll have
like two, three creatures with counters
and this will just give a plus one on
each of them. And also we don't really
want for a lot of our sagas, we don't
want counters on them. Like we don't
want to perade them because we want we
want to keep them around with Titus.
Maybe sometimes you do. Sometimes you
do.
Oh, again I'll put it in a high maybe I
because I think I I might be off there
with sagas because some sagas you can
just being able to trigger their ability
twice is actually really powerful. But
we'll have to see. See this is why is
path to exalt with destroy evil in the
same precon.
It's just not the same level of cards,
right? We could have swords to shurers
instead of this. Maybe we do. We'll see.
Path exile. Not much to say. Premier
removal. Wow. They put an offer you
can't refuse in here. It's just okay.
Really good counter spell. Not much to
say. Dusk Shell Crawler. When this
enters, put a counter on target
creature. Each creature you control with
plus one counter on it has trample.
I don't think this does enough. I know
we need evasion, but I think we have way
better cards for doing this. So, we'll
do maybe farsek ramp spell. Yeah, search
for planes or islands. Can't say no.
Inspiring call. This is another one of
those payoff cards for a counter deck.
Your creatures get indestructible. the
creatures with counter get instructible
and you draw a card for each counter
each creature that is countered.
This seems like a lot of value. You
don't even need to fire it off to
protect your board. Just to pay three
mana, draw four instant speed is really
good. Three visits, another great ramp
spell. Brad for the hunt. Whenever
another creature you control with a plus
one counter on it deals combat damage to
a player, you may draw a card.
There are better cards, but this is I
mean it's made for this deck. Where else
are you going to play this? And it's the
effect is solid. We need card draw, so
it's fine. Arcane signate. Cool.
Everflowing chalice. Yeah, synergy with
I like how they also put some thought
into the choice of manox. Let's see if
they do the same for lands. So ringing
seems good. Now on to lands.
Brushland. Canopi vista. Exotic Orchard.
Yeah, solid land choices. Facial
Fortress.
Seems good. Seems good. Yeah, all of
these I wouldn't feel bad to play except
I'm guessing there's also the Oh, they
put Temples in here. Now, Tempo are not
great are not great, but they're
serviceable and they're better than the
in the other deck where we had straight
up entering tapped lands. So, these are
okay.
Like if I ever cut lands, if I want to
replace some of my lands, these will
probably be the first to go. But we'll
see. We'll see what comes after
ash barons. Evol Oops. Evolves. Forge of
heroes.
Yeah, this just places a counter onto
our commander. Seems good. Oh, there you
go. There's I was wondering if they
didn't put these into the deck. Yeah,
these are the first to to get cut,
actually.
Yeah, they don't do anything. Nesting
grounds. Yeah, this is the same ability
as our commander. You can just move
things which is really powerful with
sagas.
Path of Does it work with sagas? Yes, it
does. Yeah. Path of ancestry. It's fine.
Yep. Sean Citadel Tangled Temple of the
False God. Why is this Why is it in this
deck? We don't have that much rep. This
card is a bit questionable because you
need five lands. Like if you get it
early, it's super awkward. But overall,
I think it's worth it. But then in this
deck, I don't know because we don't have
a ton of large mana spells. So, you'll
have to play with this and see. In this
video, we're not going to cut lands just
because we want to make more impactful
changes. But lands are definitely
important now with uh in terms of just
optimizing your deck because there's so
many excellent lands land choices now
that you can use. Okay, let's take a
look at the basics. Beautiful. Wow.
Yeah, these are nice
and treasures clue spirit. Cool. Oh
yeah, we get the counters too. Awesome.
That is the deck. And now this time I
won't forget. I will open the collector
simple booster.
First we got a summon Esper. Wow,
Valaranda. That's really cool. And a
Estinian Ver Verino.
Awesome. Yeah, we will be back to take a
look at the edits. Let's actually let's
see how many maybe how many cards are in
there. Maybe pile one 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 12 13. Okay, we will take a look at
these and maybe put in 13 cards to
replace these.
See you soon.
Okay, now that we have everything sorted
into piles by utility, let's take a
look. So, first of all, we have 37
lands. Apparently, this is the standard
that they're setting for us. Honestly, I
think it's a little bit low, but 37 for
now. We'll do. And next up, we have Next
up, we have a huge pile because unlike
the last deck, in this deck, everything
is just so synergistic. Like most of the
cards that give counter can also use
counters. So basically all these cards
can support themselves like take take
the example of the sphere grid is giving
counters to our creatures at the same
time it's pumping uh creatures with
counters. So this deck has excellent
excellent synergy and all these cards
can work with each other. And next up we
have draw spells. Now draw spells we
have 1 2 3 4 5 six seven of these. And
honestly I think seven is fine. I added
a few more, but seven is reasonable. And
next up, we have removal spells. Now, we
have a ton. Now, I'm a little bit loose
with the definition of removal, but
anything that you know bounces things
that exile things temporarily, I'm
counting them as removals. And I believe
there are 12 of these. And also,
actually 12 removals plus a counter
spell. So, 13 in total answers. This is
enough. Yeah, this is more than enough.
And also ramp. There's a ton.
Take a look.
Nine pieces of ramp. And in this deck, I
found that even though it's a blue green
deck, the top end is not heavy. If you
look at the cards, we don't have a lot
of cards over six CMC. Yeah, the highest
manacross card I can think of is sin
here. And everything else is Yeah,
there's not even a six CMC card, which
is super strange. I find uh you have a
lot of ramp, you have a lot of, you
know, you're playing a lot of card draw.
you should have some late game stuff,
which is uh this is something that I
decided to add to this deck because we
need finishers, right? We need uh bombs.
So, when it comes to the cards cut, none
of them are actually bad cards. Again,
they're all decent cards, but I just
feel like in commander, especially,
let's let's take this as an example. In
the early days, Commander precons had
tons of cards like this where they are
synergistic on paper, but they just
don't do enough. And a lot of these
cards, even though not to the extent of
this, this is the worst one. I think a
lot of these cards do things, but just
not I don't think they're worth a card
slot. So, now let's take a look at the
cards we we included. Let's make piles.
Let's make piles. Except we're going to
take this one out. And
with this pile is all the cards that I
find to be basically the best plus one
counter, the best counter cards in all
of Magic. and also some top end some
payoff just uh again if you search for
the best plus one counter cards a lot of
them would be the same but here's my
choice Denny Pink because we are a
little bit short on draw spells and this
guy is ridiculous for drawing just
behind Fathom Mage because basically it
says for each creature you control draw
a card cuz your your creatures mostly
have counters on them pretty much all of
them have counters on them and you are
proliferating so yeah this also he has
mentor so he's able multiple counters on
creatures. Next up, Kodama of the West
Tree. Another ridiculous counter payoff.
First of all, all your modified
creatures, which is creatures with
counters on them, have trample. That's
like a lorded effect, an evasion effect
that you need uh to finish the game. And
also, whenever a modified creature you
control deals combat damage, you can
search for a basic land. You can ramp
once. Yeah, this is like one of the
ultimate plus one counter payoffs. A
dream tide whale. In a multiplayer game,
this card is also ridiculous because
your opponents by mid game, they will be
casting two spells a turn. No questions.
So, you'll be getting proliferate at
least two to three times a turn and your
board will grow fast. And this will will
never will never die to vanishing. Don't
let this mislead you. It's also a three
mana 75, which is decent. Yeah.
Next up, evolution witness. The best
plus one counter recursion payoff.
Whenever you get a counter onto the
witness, you you can recur something.
Yeah, that's sweet value. Mutational
advantage, a protectional protection
spell specifically for a counter deck.
Permanence you control with counters on
them gain hexroof indestructible until
the end of turn. Prevent all damage that
will be dealt to them. This is for
planes walkers. It's not really relevant
for our deck, but the last word is
proliferate. Yeah, this card does
everything. Does everything. They think
they're wiping your board. Your board is
getting bigger.
nuts evolution stage landfall
proliferate uh because again we need
more proliferate effects for because we
we're removing counters a lot but we're
not proliferating enough and in a green
deck we have a lot of ram spells we can
trigger this once twice a turn and I
think yeah it's just such a sweet
enabler a really powerful engine
slippery bog bonder it's got flash
hexroof and when it enters you can put a
hex proof counter on target creature
then you can move any number of counters
from among creatures you control to that
creature there's a lot of synergy a lot
of play here, but just on the surface,
giving someone hexroof counter and then
you proliferate it and then you can
distribute it. You can give multiple
creatures hexroof, which is excellent
protection. And just the the flash, you
know, and the moving counters is there's
a lot of synergy, a lot of things you
can do with this Oelith. I Yeah, I was
surprised this isn't in the deck. This
is the pretty much the best plus one
counter artifact there is. It's got
cycling, too, but we're not going to
cycle it. This is amazing. Whenever we
get a counter on something, we get one
more and then it can also place counters
onto onto creatures on his own. Yeah,
just uh lots of value, lots of synergy
with our deck. The next one is Wave
Goodbye. Now, this is a blowout. Just
like the the white board wipe that said
destroy all creatures without counters,
return each creature without a plus one
counter to its owner's hand. This is a
one-sided board wipe. is like almost a
psychonic rift where you can remove all
their creatures and you can alpha strike
your opponents. We need more cards like
this. Next up is rich cars expertise.
Like I was saying earlier, we have lots
of big creatures, but we we're not doing
anything with the the massive power
aside from beating people. And there are
so many cards in green that can make use
of that large power, and this is one of
them. Uh draw cards equal to the power
of your largest picture, and you can
cast this spell for free.
Yeah, just one of the best draw spells
for green. Next up, Quilled Great Worm.
And I was saying again, we didn't have
enough top end. I think this is a great
top end for our deck. Your creatures
will get will accumulate counters so
fast. And when they kill the Great Worm,
it will just come back because you will
have enough counters to recur it. And
it's a recur a recurable threat that
keeps coming back. And yeah, with the
coolorm on the field, you're going to
finish the game much faster. Next up, we
have two pump spells because yeah,
again, you have a massive board. You
need to finish the game with it. Become
the avalanche. Draw a card for each
creature you control with power four or
greater. So, pretty much all of them.
Then they all get plus X plus X uh X's
number of cards in your hand. So, you're
going to give your board plus 6 plus
eight. Yeah, cuz you're drawing cards.
You're drawing cards with this. This is
an excellent finisher. And even if you
fail to finish, you just refill your
hand. You can you can do more damage
with something like Overwhelming
Stampede. This is the ultimate finisher.
You just need one massive creature. For
example, forgotten ancient. You pump uh
for example, if your ancient is an 88,
you will pump your board, entire board
by eight, and you can swarm them with uh
the trample, your trample fatties.
So, these are the 12 cards that I think
will make the card better and hopefully
bring it up a bracket. And I will have
the final deck list in the descriptions.
And thanks again for watching. Uh, let's
put this all together. And please like
and subscribe and comment and let me
know if you like this kind of content,
if you look forward to more. Well,
whether you look forward or not, I
already got these decks. So, this will
Yeah, this will be this will be my next
two videos. But aside from that, thank
you again for watching. I will see you
soon.